a lot of great companies take care of
their people that are exiting the
business
but they're not really thinking about
how to take care of the people
who are staying behind interesting who
are left
[Music]
amy davies thank you so much for joining
me
thank you so much for having me i'm
really excited to do this i am extremely
excited to do this because i think that
what you're doing is so
so relevant to to the unfortunate events
that have occurred in 2020 and now the
interesting thing is that you know i i
was watching a lot of the
a lot of the content about first 30 or
startup to help
both the onboarding and outplacing of
employees and a lot of it
so i saw for example a video from
september of 2019 talking about how
relevant it is to help people
as they transition to different jobs and
then i can't help but reflect on march
and april of 2020
with the massive layoffs and how how
difficult that was and thinking that
there are now these platforms like first
30 which make it easier
especially emotionally for for the
individuals not not just for the company
or the individuals or you know the focus
especially in your work
but before we get to to that i'd love to
hear a little bit about you
where do you come from i know you're in
toronto but where does your journey
start from and how do you get
to work in the space of onboarding and
out placement of employees
yeah well thanks i started my
journey i guess i started like i studied
sociology in university
i was always really interested in people
and groups of people and how they
function
and then um i went and moved to europe
for about
six years after graduation i wanted to
live in a different
society i wasn't brave enough to go
somewhere where i didn't speak the
language but i did live in
england and actually for a short time i
also lived in a very small town in
switzerland
in uh gimmelwald switzerland yeah i was
in au pair for
for a summer up there and it was amazing
but uh i lived in and worked in england
and traveled all around europe a number
of times
actually and i started working in market
research
and i actually read a book called um
what color is your parachute
and that book i mean people laugh
because it's like supposed to tell you
spit out what you're supposed to do and
it was so accurate for me
and i got into i actually this was an
interesting story i started working at
unilever
i was a i was um a temp employee
i got that job through a friend who said
unilever's the best place to be a temp
i'm gonna get you in there so it's great
to have
a good network and then i was typing
menus
i i typed the menus for the cafeteria
and i did a very bad job actually i
i anyway i really loved the
uh i loved the company and the minute i
walked in i'm like i belong
here i love the people and
i started applying for jobs internally
they're in research because it's when i
and so there was
a job on the strategy team and i got it
and actually there was a really tough
competition for the job
but i think it was just because um i
and this is what i always tell people is
make sure not
not just networking with your external
uh
uh network but also networking
internally in your
at your job so within a few months i
started work go went from typing menus
to doing strategy
for for the future of the business wow
and so that's where it kind of began
and then over the years i had different
market research jobs i came back to
canada
and started working for companies here i
worked for rogers for
mars wrigley and then i also worked for
granger
canada and you know really enjoyed it
but
always had this idea that i wanted to
help people with their careers
every business i worked with uh
beginning with unilever
all had mastery structures when i was
there
and i saw the um emotional toll it took
on people
and and even the people that didn't
leave having survivors guilt
uh staying and not really trusting the
organization
anymore i think one big miss for
companies right now is
they take care of people uh that they're
a lot of great companies take care of
their people that are exiting the
business
but they're not really thinking about
how to take care of the people
who are staying behind interesting who
are left
yeah because their productivity is
affected their commitment to the
business is affected
right and people fundamentally and i
learned this when i did market research
we feel most unwell and we're seeing it
with covid right now
when we feel out of control of our own
outcome
that impacts our well-being so badly
and when organizations go through change
what happens is people think they don't
have control over their own outcome
so one of the most important aspects of
doing the type of work that i do
is making sure people understand how
they can take
control back that's so fascinating i
have to say that because i was
reading the other day for i guess the
third or fourth time the letter that the
ceo of airbnb
sent to to their employees right when
they had the massive layoffs
and and and i was so impressed with how
they were dealing with
the communication and over communicating
and making and making it
a reasonable you know expectation
experience for them please
and i never stopped to think about how
it impacts the other employees that are
staying
you know though during all the media has
been talking about is how the leaders
are communicating
externally to the ones who are leaving
and taking care of them but i don't
think there's been
any real coverage about how employers
are
looking internally and and working about
working on the culture so i think it's a
really fascinating thing that you're
bringing up here
um yeah and i i agree with you
we just sort of assume people will just
snap back but i've been through so many
restructures and
sometimes my role has been affected it's
always been affected in the sense i've
changed teams changed leadership
not always lost my job but
i see that even six months a year later
people
still talk about that day when their
colleagues were laid off and they have a
lot of pain associated with that and
insecurity around it right right okay so
you so you've gone through these massive
structurings which is obviously an
inevitable part of many many companies
it's also a natural part as companies
progress and they pivot and they
and they have to change strategy and and
then how do
how do you come to this idea for for
first
30 because companies have been
onboarding and outplacing employees for
hundreds of years right i mean this is a
the natural thing to do in the economy
yes
so where does this where does this idea
come from
yeah well i want to just point out that
i agree with you there it is natural
companies
need to restructure so i i do believe
that companies need to do this
and i do also believe there's right ways
and wrong ways
to do it um and i talk about a lot about
the fact and part of the title of my
book is all about living in a re-org
world
so um what happened with first 30 was
i was put through two different
outplacements over the
course of my career and i thought wow
this is so great to be given the service
but the whole time i thought oh there's
something different we can be doing
and then of course i naturally did what
i do best
was i did started researching and i
found out how expensive
first of all the outplacement companies
were for
uh for businesses so come out placement
companies can charge
anywhere from about three thousand
dollars to about fifteen thousand
dollars per employee
i don't think a lot of people are aware
no that's crazy wait
what what what do they do these are
placement companies
like what is that what is the role all
kinds of yeah
there's all kinds of different things so
people can get together
for uh group sessions to come in and
have a presentation on a topic like
uh branding yourself or uh networking
all kinds of different topics
they can get their resume reviewed they
can have a coach
work with them but then when i would so
the coaches what is costing
the uh company the most money that
one-to-one personal coaching
and employees so they're exiting
employees i know this because i did
research with dozens of people i'm like
always the phone a friend for anyone who
loses their job so
i i spoke to and i of course uh treated
it like a research project and i had my
list of questions
and so the way that the personal coaches
were described to me
was what that they were kind of
formulaic in their approach
and that the person didn't really get
their industry they didn't get their
work level
and they didn't really get them as a
person so
that was one of the things they said
they were most excited about about these
programs
but it it's what disappointed them the
most
because of their expectation was so
great so that's when i thought about how
could i
put together a program that had a lot of
virtual components
that felt very uh
that gave them a strong connection with
it uh and also took them along a journey
but and the other thing that there was a
big point
sorry same point a bloop you could do a
little blooper reel from this i guess
you're putting it all in you don't edit
right
that's the beauty of it yeah the other
um pain point was that when they get on
online portals because a lot of these
businesses set up online portals
it was like a resource dump so there was
all these
resources but and then you know you're
stressed and anxious
so the way that i organized first 30 was
very
thoughtful so it's so clear if you've
got a job interview
you know exactly where to go in that
program to get the help that you need
but we also do all of the same things
that these outplacement businesses do
we do resume reviews we have a great
resume expert
sheet camara to follow and she actually
does like
videos and she'll re review people's
resume
on video and then it will be sent to
them so they can see exactly what they
need to do to change and they always
have that video saved
and so i really try to find the best of
the best it's really important to me to
work with the very very best people
and provide the absolute best service it
just so happens
because of the approach we've taken we
can also do it at a fraction of the cost
of traditional outplacement so just so
that i know so just for the high level
sake
the the idea behind first 30 is an
alternative to these
very expensive out placement companies
that
an organization that is going through a
restructuring or layoffs
uh or onboarding they can come to first
30 which is an online platform
that is personalized to the person who's
going through
the the layoff or the onboarding and
gives them personal resources whether it
be
finding a doing their own branding their
resume revamp
understanding what other opportunities
there are and understanding i'm guessing
the
the whole way of how how this is going
to happen right because i'm sure there
are a lot of questions for somebody
who's getting laid off
how do you like what like what's gonna
happen with my compensation how like
what do i have to take care of now right
yeah so there's not a lot on the
compensation part because we are not uh
lawyers and so it's really important
that if they have those types of
questions there's all kinds of lawyers
that they can contact and that is what i
would recommend to people
um if they feel like they're uh
they need to review that with their
employer um but we do give them all
kinds of so it starts kind of at the
beginning of the journey like how they
must be feeling
right away they meet our uh clinical
psychologist
uh dr mary lynn who's in the program and
she talks to them
about how to kind of move forward it's
all
about moving forward and taking control
taking care of your well-being but also
growing
as a professional so a huge part and we
run
sorry i was the only thing i was gonna
add is every two weeks or so we also run
webinars
i'm always there sometimes i bring in an
expert guest
and i love the way that you do this
because this is the way we do our
webinars
we're talking with each other i'm trying
to open it up now so they can start
the audience members can start
contributing so we do these all the time
and they're very organized because
there's a
very clear purpose and clear outtakes
but they're also very open
and i've been there so i'm not
like i'm not talking at anybody we're
having a conversation together
and that's kind of the beauty of the
program right and
and it's all about the individual at the
end right so one of the things also
and i i think that it's part of the
focus in your book is this idea of
individual empowerment
and and not just looking at it from an
organizational perspective but looking
at it as how
each individual is going to pers is
going to go through this either a
difficult process of outplacement or or
the the happy but complicated process of
onboarding right
yeah the book itself the book is called
a spark in the dark illuminating your
path to a brilliant career in a re-org
world
so the the book has been published
that's on amazon
it's also for people for companies who
register their employees in the program
it's in the program too
the audio edition is actually being
launched to the public
in september congrats that book
thank you that book is all about um
really what the world looks like today
what the career world looks like of
course covet has had a huge
impact and the book was written before
that but it actually
is a great book to read when you're
going and you're really trying to make
uh have a successful career in this
world because that's precisely what i'm
talking about
it answers the question how do you have
a successful career when you're losing
or changing your job every two to three
years
because nobody's doing it for you you uh
we
i always hear this being said that no
one cares more about your career than
you
right so you better take the helm and do
something
because it's not just gonna happen and i
fear that
i always make the joke that the next
book that i'm gonna write is how to
raise
kids other people like because
likability is so
strongly connected to your career
outcome
but i think so many people are going
into the corporate world and with very
loving parents
who have told them that they're really
good at so many things
and i fear that they're going out there
and finding out that it's
you know we may be special to our loved
ones
but we're not going to be treated like
we're special in the world
and because being special it's it is
special right like you're different than
everybody else and of course we all have
our unique
abilities we're special to the people we
love but we're not necessarily
special if that makes sense i hate to
say that it's such a gloomy
but when you get out in your career
that's one of the first things that
people realize is you got to do the
tough work to
i've done it you know i'm sure you're
doing it like you're in school you
you're starting a career like you're
doing the tough slog to get there
it doesn't all happen overnight right
right so what are some of the the key
insights that you've gained over the
past
over the past few years understanding
this ecosystem
so as you know as a young entrepreneur
myself going on my journey and a lot of
my friends who are running companies
what are some key things that we need to
keep in mind from an a leadership
perspective
on the whole process of onboarding and
outplacing employees except of course
from using
first 30 as an aid for our for our
people
yeah well i do think that you have to
consider the benefits
when you onboard your employees very
well
your intention your retention will be a
lot higher that's proven
in research that come employees stay
longer they're more productive right
away
and it will help your overall employer
brand
both to onboard really well with
excellence
and to treat the employees that are
leaving really well it's a very very
small world i'm sure you're finding that
especially
doing all these shows i mean your world
just keeps getting smaller and smaller
i think it's great but i would say make
sure that you treat people
well because it will have a
real financial impact on your business
when you don't
so when i work with suppliers even
i make sure that i pay my suppliers what
they're worth
i don't you know i don't try to to get
them down to pricing because
why wouldn't i just pay if it's a
quality service and
you know they're an entrepreneur just
like me i work with a lot of other
entrepreneurs
who have built the first 30 anyone who
goes to the first 30 website it's
first30ready.com will see the beautiful
branding
on the website and that isn't me
that's my designer james white and he
and i have an amazing relationship
and the developers did a fantastic job
and i do
think that it's how you treat people
just in general
whether you're they're your employees or
your suppliers
and to um pay them what they're worth
yeah so i don't know if that helps and
it's not specifically about onboarding
and outplacement
but not any entrepreneur going yeah
going out on their own
do not cut corners when it comes to how
you
uh pay people and how you treat them
because
um the work will just be better right
so obviously you're a researcher at
heart and it exudes from the
from the conversation and from your
journey what do you see
as sort of the future of of onboarding
and outplacement let's say in 10 20
years do you think that the workforce is
going to continue at the trajectory of
you know every two to three years you
change jobs especially in the tech
ecosystem
or or do you do you expect some some
radical shifts due to covid
well certainly there's going to be
radical shifts due to covet there's new
job new types of jobs
opening up all the time i do i do
believe that we're all going to be
seeing that we're going to be having
multiple different jobs
multiple different careers over our
career path
uh that is not going to change because
the world is changing so
quickly and the what we need
what we need in terms of specialties and
people what people are capable of doing
that will change and it should change
and i
i think people help themselves career
professionals help themselves
by being aware that we live in this rear
world so you can kind of get ahead of it
and keep skilling up if you need to
skill up and
looking around and see never ever ever
get complacent
so yes i think we're going to keep
seeing the world continue to change
restructuring happening
where um and i do like to think that
that opens
up opportunities i i don't like when i
see people lose their job
but i certainly know what to do to help
them when they do so
i'm very happy to have launched verse 30
i think that type of business will have
a lot of potential in the future
i love for sure amy yeah 20 minutes go
by way too fast and i want to talk about
unbelievable right and i want to uh
thank you for being so generous with
your time i know how busy you are
and but before we leave i have to ask
the most important question three words
that you would use to describe yourself
well i'll use two words and a phrase
because in the book i talk about an
illuminate exercise where you
figure out who you are and what you want
to convey to the world
and at every single touch point be that
person
um so mine are i'm strong
i'm sincere and if you know me i make
your life better
and those are the three things that i
try i
am and i try to convey every day at
every touch point
amy thank you very very much this was
very very insightful
thank you and and i look forward to
definitely sharing this
platform and and hopefully a you know
using it myself
to to empower the people that i'll get
to work with and i have a meaningful
experience for everybody and they
it's definitely something that's hugely
relevant over the past over the past few
months especially but
but moving forward and the trajectory of
rewards the workforce is going
it sounds like a right place right time
so so thank you very much and good luck
oh thank you i really enjoyed this and
all the best
you